Hello everybody welcome I know people
are still coming in I'm Stephen pity I'm
professor of History American studies
and ethnicity race and migration here at
Yale and I direct the Yale center for
the study of race indigeneity and
transnational migration I want to thank
my colleagues in ritm Victoria Mary and
Nicole for helping to put this together
today really excited to have all of you
here
um I learned a long time ago
uh that one wants to listen to
everything that Laura Briggs says uh and
read everything that Laura Briggs writes
about many of the critical topics facing
the world right now ranging from
transnational feminist movements to the
politics of reproduction
intersections of Empire and migration
the welfare state the health and safety
of children the past and future of
neoliberal governance and much much more
she's just one of the most thoughtful
and most persuasive and most
well-informed people you'll ever meet
uh Professor Briggs is Professor of
women's gender and sexuality studies at
the University of Massachusetts at
Amherst she earned her PhD in American
studies from Brown University
she's authored a number of field
changing and prize-winning books
including reproducing Empire race sex
and U.S imperialism in Puerto Rico
International Adoption Global
inequalities and the circulation of
children
how all politics became reproductive
politics from welfare reform to
foreclosure to Trump
and taking children a history of
American Terror
and she's co-edited important volumes
including somebody's children the
politics of transnational and
transracial adoption and a special issue
of meridians on radical
transnationalisms reimagining
solidarities violence Empires
he's now working on a book entitled the
future is born in small places the
gendered biopolitics of Freedom Debt
imperialism and a natural disaster in
the Caribbean
we'll have to have you back when that
books uh when Yale's ritm Center
considered who we'd like to invite to
deliver our fall 2022 lecture we knew
right away uh that that person was Laura
Briggs an outstanding scholar and a
great teacher she's an active series
editor at the University of California
press a program Builder who's worked on
the organizing collectives of the tepo
salon Institute for transnational
history and the the thinking
transnational feminism summer Institute
and in the migration Scholars Collective
and she's been an unceasing and wise
contributor to public conversations
through her appearances on radio
television and podcasts and in the print
media her talk today is entitled taking
children as a tactic of Terror producing
neoliberalism and making a crisis of
immigration and Asylum thank you so much
for coming Laura Briggs
[Applause]
thank you Stephen for that lovely
introduction I have to tell you all as I
was driving down here I was listening to
an audiobook I was listening to
celestings our missing Hearts which is
about lost children
um and it's about the fight to even be
able to tell the stories of lost
children so it was
um it was quite a fitting thing to be
doing as I was trying to get ready for
this talk so thank you so much for
giving me this opportunity to do just
that
so in April and May of 2018 the Trump
administration's policy of separating
children from parents mostly from
Central America seeking asylum in the
United States made headlines
photos of children torn from their
parents arms filled to media in the
United States an audio tape of separated
children in a shelter crying seemed to
be everywhere
calling the policy zero tolerance and
then U.S attorney general Jeff sessions
and Homeland Security Chief kirchen
Nielsen
said they were trying to deter people
from petitioning for Asylum in the face
of massive protests and a court ordered
to reunite parents and children the
Trump Administration walked the policy
back and announced they would no longer
do it
nine months later though children dying
in Customs and Border Protection custody
and a flu epidemic in a detention camp
in Texas brought doctors and lawyers
then lawmakers and activists to the
camps
Border Patrol was in fact still
separating children from parents more
than 5 000 of them in total
they were holding them for weeks and
months without beds blankets showers or
change of clothes and processing
stations designed to hold adults for
less than 48 hours
one doctor described the squalid
conditions of what children were being
held but where children were being held
as tantament to the intentional spread
of disease calling them torture
facilities
until the Trump Administration figured
out how to use the pandemic and public
health laws to exclude Asylum Seekers
Customs and Border Protection
deliberately targeted parents and
children
separating them at the border as part of
a policy meant to deter Asylum Seekers
from entering the country the cruelty
was the point as Adam sewer at the
Atlantic first said
a widely circulated photo of a father
and his toddler daughter floating dead
in the Rio Grande suggested the terror
that Asylum Seekers faced while being
metered in Mexico for weeks and months
unable to cross the border and petition
for Asylum
and then forcing them into refugee camps
on the U.S Mexico border like this one
to criticize in the Biden
administration's response to the Asylum
crisis especially from Latin America
with a record low number of immigrants
and refugees admitted to the U.S
accepting the two years of the pandemic
and what I want you to see on this slide
is that the ceiling for refugees has
been set quite high but the actual
number of refugees admitted is way down
in that yellow earnshine
until this month the Biden
administration had begun to empty
refugee camps of mostly Central American
migrants in Mexico like the one from the
previous slide in Matamoros camps that
at their height contained thousands of
people
this Administration has actually worked
to reunite Children and Families
successfully putting to putting back
together around 500 of them that were
separated by the Trump Administration
although 200 still remain lost to each
other
in recent weeks as a new wave of
venezuelan's flea economic collapse at
home shelters and encampments in Mexico
have begun to fill again even more
seemingly under pressure from Washington
rumor has had it that Mexican officials
are pushing Venezuelans still further
south across the border into Guatemala
and even as the Biden Administration is
engaged in lawsuits to end expulsions
under title 42 the public health measure
that's been used to deport people since
the covid pandemic began without any
semblance of an asylum process
it has recently expanded such expulsions
Again by using them to against
Venezuelans just as it did months ago to
ukrainians
above all of course what people need
from the U.S immigration system is a
simple efficient and predictable Pathway
to citizenship not the Byzantine
arbitrary and capricious system we have
now
children and adults are Crossing Borders
for any number of reasons but these
include importantly seeking to reunite
after many decades of a racialized labor
system in the United States that once
immigrant workers but not their
households
not children not Elders the ongoing
disruptions of everyday life for
impoverished people in Central America
Venezuela and Mexico has produced an
asylum crisis and this includes the ways
that the IMF World Bank and ngos have
methodically destroyed National
governments in many nations in Central
America opening the door to corruption
and to drug cartels taking over
Municipal governments and incorporating
themselves as ngos building
organizations that extend from Honduras
to the U.S Southwest
made much worse by state-sponsored
violence in the aftermath of the U.S
sponsored coup in Honduras in 2009 and
contested elections in 2017.
the way his opponents of the child
separation policy organized both helped
and hindered the effort to address these
problems
the first thing we have to acknowledge
is that there's nothing exceptional
about taking children
from their kin and caregivers this has
been a practice up and down the Americas
for four centuries targeting single
mothers and others without
heteronormative families especially
enslaved people and members of tribal
Nations
treating child separation is remarkable
in some ways kept us from actually
stopping it
as it allowed the Trump Administration
to claim in 2019 that it was just taking
children from parents who had been
neglectful or who had a criminal history
we have not been good ever at addressing
the ways these charges have a history in
this country of being directed at black
and Indigenous communities in rebellion
and all the people Kathy Cohen
identified as queer the welfare mothers
The Single Moms the unruly Youth and all
those who are bad at nuclear families
in order to understand the trump-era
policy of taking children from Asylum
Seekers and putting them in detention
camps we need to ask how Central
Americans were made into the sorts of
people who could be dispossessed of
their children
how did it come to be in the spring of
2018 that immigration officials walked
the bridge of the Americas between
Juarez and Mexico and picked Central
Americans out of crowds of people from
every country continent and island that
walked that Sky Bridge
why were Central Americans in particular
told that the United States was full and
they could not cross
it's one immigration activist said if
you look indigenous or you look Central
American they will stop you they never
ask why you are coming they just say
they can't receive you
the policy didn't spring fully formed
from the head of a trump Administration
official in 2018. it had a history in
The anti-communist Civil Wars of the
latter part of the 20th century when
Central Americans first began losing
their children to State Terror
foreign
Americans in the 1960s 70s and 80s had a
child taking by those who sought to
instantiate neoliberalism Across the
region through anti-communist rhetoric
there in the space between Henry
Kissinger and Ronald Reagan's America
fascist Spain and Latin America's own
autonomous nationalism militarism and
right-wing Catholicism
increasingly paranoid anti-communist
States sought to rigidly control not
only the present but the future
military dictatorships up and down Latin
America from Guatemala to Argentina
directed campaigns of torture
assassination and disappearance
while initially these right-wing
military dictatorships targeted armed
leftist gorillas
their victims grew more diverse as they
quickly overwhelmed and largely killed
actual militants turning to those who
supported anything even vaguely
socialist from unions to students to
agrarian cooperatives
then they took their children hoping to
ensure that the very young who might
have been touched by their parents
leftist ideas were violently uprooted
and re-educated in conservative adoptive
families or outside the country
this right-wing dream of killing ideas
by burying their proponents and taking
their children was a failure
as the extent of torture and especially
the kidnapping of children became known
to ever wider circles
there were first efforts to prosecute
them in 2006 Jorge Rafael videla once
the most powerful man in Argentina as
its military dictator went to prison
together with a number of his
collaborators not for his responsibility
for torture murder and disappearances
but rather for kidnapping children and
running an illegal adoption ring while
he was the de facto president in the
late 70s and early 80s
while the Argentine Congress had tried
to Grant a general amnesty to the former
leaders to prevent press their
prosecution for the crimes they
committed as they oversaw hundreds of
torture centers and while giving orders
for the military to kill civilians a
judge found that the official pardon
didn't cover child kidnapping
because it was an ongoing crime
continuing after the final date of the
amnesty
kidnapped infants and children turned
out to be the crime they could be
prosecuted for and it's what held them
in prison until the amnesty was finally
repealed in 2005.
in El Salvador in the late 1970s more
and more people despaired of free and
fair elections is demonstrating for them
got people killed
and they turn to support the leftist
military guardias
in the U.S The Carter Administration to
a small degree and then the Reagan
Administration massively gave a corrupt
Salvadoran State support in the form of
training for the military
they gave them weapons military advisors
and ultimately about one to two million
US dollars a day
to prop up a brutal and unpopular
government
the Salvadoran government held power
through Terror detentions and
disappearances death squads that left
bodies in the streets as a warning to
others about opposing the government and
massacres of Civilian communities that
were suspected of support for the
gorillas
during the armed internal conflict an
estimated 75 000 civilians were killed
in a country of only 5 million people
the overwhelming majority died at the
hands of the military
and paramilitary forces in El Salvador
also took between 800 and a thousand
children
during the conflict the military sought
to eliminate the social base of the
Guerrilla drawing on the U.S military's
Paradigm in Vietnam they sought to
eliminate the water the fish of the
gorillas swam in engaging in a scorched
Earth campaign against civilians and
creating model Villages surrounded by
barbed wire and guarded by military and
paramilitary units in place of
autonomous communities
foreign
their goals included breaking people's
will to resist by sowing Terror
including of losing children and as in
Argentina to control the future
by refusing to allow those suspected of
being communists from raising a Next
Generation
sometimes children became lost on the
confusion when military threat forced
communities to flee
others were picked up right in front of
their parents and there were cases where
they were literally ripped from their
mother's arms
according to their reconstruction and
research
from the stories of surviving relatives
human rights groups attributed 90
percent of the child disappearance cases
to the military and 10 percent to the
gorillas
in late May and early June of 1982 to
take only one example in the events that
became known as the guinda de Mayo the
flight in May people ran from their
homes because they were tipped off the
paramilitary groups in the Army were
planning to come to their homes and kill
them believing that they were supporters
of the gorillas
the military called this operation
cleanup operations
designed to wipe out communities in
Northeast chalatanango
people fled from one Community to
another with soldiers on their heels who
killed anyone they found
they slaughtered animals and destroyed
homes and crops
these forces also took at least 11
children including ernestina and erlina
Serrano Cruz ages three and seven
when the Serrano Cruz family began
running the mother and a brother made it
past military barricade and went in One
Direction while the father brother and
sister suyapa ernestina and erlino and
another
after three days of walking they made it
to a settlement
they hid there for another three days
without food or water
but finally the brothers went to search
for water
ernestina and erlina small children
alone began to cry tipping off soldiers
to the presence
to their presence
so yappa was not far away but she had a
six-month-old baby and she'd tried to
protect her family by hiding separately
in case the baby cried
she later reported that she heard one
soldier ask if they should take
ernestina and erlina or kill them
another replied that they should take
them
when she no longer heard the soldiers
suyapa went and searched for her sisters
but they were gone the little girls were
never found
after the war a Human Rights group
Association
the association for searching for
disappeared children
began the painful work with families of
trying to find children disappeared
during the war war
they found about 500 some of them
adopted in Europe some in the United
States others in Salvador and continued
to look for others
well it took Decades of work for their
lawyers the case that ultimately broke
open the impunities surrounding the
military child taking was that of the
Serrano Cruise girls
the inter-american court of Human Rights
ruled in 2005 that the state was
responsible for their disappearances and
demanded that it opened its records to
help find them and form a national
search commission which it did albeit
not until six years later
the court also found that the military
unit that took the girls was the
infamous atlucado Battalion
responsible for numerous massacres and
atrocities during the war
this is particularly significant for the
still unanswered question of whether U.S
military and intelligence advisors
widely believed to have trained
Salvadorans and torture and responsible
for their scorched Earth strategy we're
also involved with Salvador's child
kidnapping policy
the atlacado Battalion was trained by
the US military in the school of the
Americas in North Carolina and was
directly advised by them once they
returned to El Salvador
the New York Times called the Battalion
the pride of the United States military
team in San Salvador
even if U.S advisors did not directly
urge child taking and we don't know if
they did or didn't
it's difficult to believe that they
never heard anything about it
some children were even living in
military barracks and every child who
was adopted transnationally to the U.S
passed through the U.S embassy in San
Salvador
as Robert White U.S ambassador tell
Salvador in 1980 and 81 set of the
efforts to cover over the horrors of
what the Salvadoran leadership and
Military was doing by the Reagan
Administration and to a lesser extent
the bush and Carter Administrations
the Salvadoran military knew that we
knew
and they knew when we covered up the
truth
it was a clear signal that at a minimum
we tolerated this
if they knew and didn't speak against it
U.S officials aided an abetted child
taking
although Guatemala shares a border with
El Salvador they're quite different
kinds of places and the Civil Wars had
very different Dynamics
one could say that about the Central
America region as a whole
Nicaragua the gorilla is one in El
Salvador they almost won
in Guatemala they had an uphill battle
but were stopped by genocide when they
were beginning to make progress and in
Honduras in part due to the U.S military
presence they never got off the ground
Guatemala are much larger than Salvador
is much larger than Salvador and its
people speak more than 20 different
languages
about half her indigenous many of whom
live in remote communities in the
highlands that are a day's walk From Any
Road
if El Salvador is finally coming to a
Reckoning with child taking in the 1980s
guatemalas encounter with its cold war
Horrors is still ongoing and perhaps a
losing battle
El Salvador has a relatively complete
counting of the hundreds of children
that were lost during the war and many
of them have been found Guatemala lacks
anything like a comprehensive account of
the more than 5 000 or children who were
disappeared
there a paranoid Latino ruling class
feared the autonomous non-speaking
non-spanish-speaking indigenous Mayan
communities
some lengthy Shield speaking Maya of a
remote region of the Highlands that's a
picture of somebody in a new Shield
community
we're identified as a group as
subversives
Guerrilla sympathizers are worse and
targeted for elimination
while the military rulers denied it to
the world and most Guatemalans in the
major urban areas tried to pretend it
wasn't happening
the military committed atrocities and
massacres in the highlands slipping into
communities in the early morning hours
and killing everyone
destroying crops killing animals burning
homes
they reveled and grew some ways to end
the life in a human body whether of men
women or children
they raised 440 communities with the
intimate and extensive cooperation of
U.S military advisers and the CIA
where they didn't assassinate they
captured people and disappeared children
the effects of taking small children and
disappearing them are similar everywhere
the Exquisite pain of the loss of a
loved one compounded by the uncertainty
of what happened to them and the agony
of having failed someone who said who
was so deeply dependent on you
here's a quote from somebody in
Guatemala
my name is Feliciano Raymundo and I
remember that after they disappeared
Jose in 1982 they killed my husband and
disappeared my other Sons
I became ill from the pure sorrow and
suffering
during the following 18 years I was able
to find three of my sons but I wasn't
able to learn about my Jose I don't know
what happened
sometimes I thought that maybe he had
died and other times I felt that he was
alive I always kept alive that hope and
I wondered who does my son live with
could he be married where would he be
living
other days sadness would get the better
of me and I would think that it would
have been better if I hadn't left him
with someone in a place where she had
thought he would have been safer
if I had done other things in those days
surely Jose would not have been lost
survivors grieved without resolution
the armed forces and the paramilitaries
in Guatemala did not kill all the
children they picked up
they also took them to other indigenous
communities for adoption or dropped them
off at orphanages where they made their
way to Europe or the United States and
adoption sometimes
or took them to towns and cities
one of the tactics of the vast
bureaucracy of the military and
intelligence Services which effectively
encircled the entire nation through its
net network of orejas of informants and
spies was to pit indigenous peoples
against each other
the goal of Disappearing children was
the logic of ideological and genocidal
elimination to disrupt the transmission
of languages ways of life
the practic the Practical Arts of
weaving Weepies or blouses to eliminate
ways of thinking and acting
sometimes even during the war
people would learn that their children
were still alive
but growing up in a community that spoke
a different language and was loyal to
the government
on the one hand they spoke of it being a
relief to find them alive but they were
also full of grief to find that they
that their children were now in some
sense also part of the academy that
might return to kill them in all their
community
thank you
the Peace Accords were officially signed
in 1996 but the Civic process of
building peace was never completed
the now grown children who were
kidnapped are still searching for their
families and communities while parents
and relatives keep looking for them
as elsewhere in Latin America
family members of Los Tesa parasitos
were a political force demanding that
children who were taken alive be found
unlike an El Salvador Argentina however
in Guatemala the same people who were
who were found responsible for acts of
genocide by the truth commissions often
stayed in power
two reports from the archbishops
commission on human rights one in 1998
the other in 2000 collected testimony on
first 216 children disappeared alive and
later than 444
this latter report Austin
until you are found focused exclusively
on disappeared children and suggested
that there were many many more cases
in 1999 a number of groups of relatives
of the Disappeared came together to
begin the massive task of trying to
reunite children with the families who
lost them under the umbrella of Toro
sport encuentro
by 2008 they had organized 650 reunions
bringing together translators often more
than one since many monolingual speakers
of indigenous languages were involved
and gathered the resources for the often
long trips across the country on buses
and on foot
these emotional reunions often brought
out whole communities to celebrate
though the renewed connections were
often fleeting in the face of TR of the
expense of travel and the absence of a
shared language
well most of us know something and many
of us know a lot about Central America's
Wars and the U.S sponsorship of them now
I want to talk about the more
clandestine War the part that was funded
by drugs
the Reagan Administration played a much
bigger role than policy experts usually
want to acknowledge in birthing the
Contemporary era of drug cartels and
drug trafficking although the general
outlines were laid out near-end Contra
hearings and subsequently the Kerry
commission hearings on drugs and foreign
policy
obviously part of this was just
destroying the formal economy through
War
so-called development loans and building
and bringing to power a ruling class
that shrank the state and often did
nothing to build Health Care education
or food subsidies leaving the informal
economy drugs in particular is one of
the few ways to make a buck and
literally in El Salvador it's a buck
right they're using U.S currency
but also when Congress cut off funding
for the anti-communist wars in Central
America as it became clear that the
kinds of militaries and paramilitaries
that the Reagan Administration was
supporting were engaged in torture
disappearances and bodies in the streets
and kidnapping children
a shadow U.S government operation
allowed them to fund themselves in Shady
ways including flying bricks of cocaine
into U.S cities on military planes
indeed these networks are the origins of
the current cartels that are terrorizing
impoverished people especially women and
children throughout Central America and
Mexico and sometimes the us as well
driving the current Asylum crisis on the
Southwest border
the 1980s was also when children seeking
Refuge from Central America's Wars who
walked or got a ride across the U.S
border started being held in cages
despite the Trump exceptionalism that
led many to believe that child
separation for Asylum was new for Asylum
Seekers was new
Central American children have been sent
to detention camps and separated from
their parents for decades
first Mexico and secondarily Central
America came in the 20th century to
function as a kind of Labor reserve for
the United States
agribusiness service Industries and the
construction sector alongside employers
of housekeepers and nannies relied on
being able to access a labor force that
under the shadow of deportation could be
expected to work cheaply and outside the
legal system of Labor protections like
minimum wage
in time of Labor over Supply these same
workers could be pushed back into Latin
America in times of shortage more could
be recruited
the arrival of large numbers of children
signaled the death of this tacit bargain
however
the deal was essentially that workers
would not stay in the United States
although that was always a fantasy more
than a reality
and Employers in local communities would
not pay the costs of reproducing the
labor force children would stay in home
countries to get educated get their
health care and grow to an age where
they could be of use as workers
when people became too old or disabled
to work they'd be forced back across the
border
in this way Latin America function like
South Africa's homelands are bound to
stands under apartheid a reserve where
women children and Elders were expected
to subsist off a worker's remittances or
whatever farming they could Scratch Out
in the 1980s the system began to falter
in Central America as adults and
children fled Wars at home
women became a larger and larger group
of migrants often bringing children
across the border as well
by the 1990s with the Bill Clinton era
militarization of the border the system
broke down even further as workers could
no longer return to home countries to
birth their father children renew
relationships with children or Partners
or visit Elders as they were dying
by 2014 when Central American children
started arriving unaccompanied in
significant numbers it was clear that
the border militarization and
deteriorating conditions of violence
victimizing impoverished people in the
region had completely destroyed the old
system
unaccompanied children actually began
filing Asylum petitions in numbers after
2000 claiming a human right to safety as
drug cartels police violence and
impunity economic collapse and gangs
threaten their well-being in order to
continue to feed the Apparently
insatiable appetite for drugs in the
United States
U.S social policy continued to try to
keep the old labor agreement in place
its collapse was why conservatives and
white nationalists were and are in a
dead Panic about small children crossing
the border
as soon as there were significant
numbers of central Americans in the U.S
Southwest there were children in
detention camps and separated from their
parents
most sought to find relatives and
disappear into the general population
which became easier at Central American
immigrant communities grew
while many slipped across the border
unnoticed The Unlucky ones were picked
up by the ins between 7 400 and 8 500
children a year between 1987 and 1993.
they were strip surged detained and then
usually released to parents or Guardians
to await hearings on immigration charges
they were also for a time large
sprawling Red Cross camps at the Texas
Mexico border that has Central American
families
in 1985 John England said Flores was
part of a group of children who were
held for months or years as a result of
new ins rules that prevented her release
to a guardian
the ins the i in the immigration
Naturalization Service I just looked
around and realized that some of you
have only known it as ice
um
decided it would only release children
in custody to a mother father or
grandparent aunt or uncle and only if
they could prove that they were in
status in the United States
if Jenny Flores his mother had picked
her up she would essentially be turning
herself in as an undocumented immigrant
and become subject to deportation
her husband had been killed in El
Salvador and this was not something she
was willing to do
so instead she turned to Carlos Holguin
an attorney with the national Center for
immigrant rights
Oakland took the Reagan Administration
to court on immigrant child detention
the conditions under which children were
held and the question of whether they
should be detained at all
he sought to get Jenny Flores release to
a cousin arguing that she was better off
with him than an in an old hotel that
had been converted into an immigration
Detention Facility
sharing a room with three adult male
strangers strip searched with no minimal
standards and force for health
sanitation or access to education or
age-appropriate diversions
the court and the ins proved much more
willing to clean up the conditions of
immigrant immigrant detention for
children than to release them
the florist case ultimately split into
three one on strip searches one on
whether Refugee and immigrant children
could be detained at all and one
subsequently on the conditions of that
detention in Flores V nice
in 1987 the Reagan Administration
tentatively agreed to safer and more
Humane conditions in detention the
Flores V Mis settlement agreement
the Flores agreement which is um
still in force supposedly
um stipulated that children would only
be held for a few days in the least
restrictive setting a licensed
non-secure facility to determine whether
they should be deported or reunited with
relatives otherwise they would be placed
in foster homes or licensed facilities
with age-appropriate programs
the most important part of the forest
litigation in my view was the Supreme
Court case to determine whether children
should be put in Immigration detention
at all
the Reagan and first Bush Administration
aggressively defended the practice of
holding about 2 000 children a year
they sought to keep detaining children
even after the ninth circuit ruled that
they had released them to relatives
appealing it to the Supreme Court in
Barbie Flores and yes that bar Bill Barr
also the Attorney General under Trump
in the um
in that case the government's strategy
was to defend attention by arguing it
was Humane and home-like
advocates for migrant children painted a
much different picture citing nine
different child advocacy groups who
testified to shackling barbed wire
arbitrary punishment inadequate food
lack of access to counsel or phones
one youth who is subsequently sent to
juvenile hall in California described
the vast Improvement there over ins
detention conditions
in 1993 by a 5-4 majority
the High Court ruled in favor of keeping
children in detention with Antonin
Scalia writing for the majority that
where the conditions of government
custody are decent and Humane such
custody surely does not violate the
constitution
and it's the 10 in his descent Justice
Stevens insisted that on the contrary
jailing children for offenses that were
legally as weighty as a parking ticket
was obscene
during the Clinton years little changed
about 200 children were being held in
long-term immigrant detention at any
given time some of whom though not all
had requested Asylum
in 1997 a Human Rights Watch report
damned the practice of jailing children
particularly those who were lawfully
present in the U.S because they had
petitioned for Asylum
and called on the ins to release
children to relatives or child welfare
agencies to inform them of their legal
rights and to provide education and
books and Detention Center
the report was embarrassing to the
Clinton Administration and so it finally
concluded the negotiations over the
Florida settlement
begun under Reagan if children must be
held it would be under safe and sanitary
conditions and a licensed child welfare
facility with access to food and water
Medical Care adequate temperature
control and lawyers and segregated from
unrelated adults and young prisoners
charged with crimes
unfortunately the florist agreement was
never sufficient in itself to deter
abuse by immigration officials
the George W Bush Administration
detained small children
with their parents and unaccompanied
minors under far harsher conditions than
the Clinton Administration or even
Reagan
following the September 11
2001 events
the Bush Administration began separating
children from parents for the first time
and parents from each other
instead of family detention they like
the Trump Administration subsequently
created a legal fiction of these being
unaccompanied children by virtue of
having been separated from their
caregivers by the ins
which is exactly what the Trump
Administration subsequently did
an Amnesty International report in 2003
called attention to these conditions and
they found the second Bush
Administration and Customs and Border
Protection
essentially ignored the Flores rules for
child detention
according to Amnesty International child
migrants were spending years in
detention without judicial review of
their claims
to stay in the U.S
strip searches had been reinstituted
they were housed with juveniles
convicted of crimes beaten by guards and
subjected to solitary and confinement
for infractions like poor sportsmanship
swearing or even grammatical mistakes
children as young as seven were brought
to immigration hearings and shackles
with belly chains and leg irons
in 2005 the Congressional Appropriations
Committee ordered the Bush
Administration to stop separating
families telling them to use ankle
monitors to ensure parents appeared at
their Asylum hearings
rather than release families though the
Bush Administration expanded family
detention
where the previous system had relied on
a single small facility the Burke's
Detention Center in Pennsylvania the
Bush Administration opened a much larger
one to hold more families the tea Don
Hato detention center near Austin Texas
it quickly became a symbol of the
abusiveness of the system
a former medium security prison for men
it lacked the Green Space of Burks a
former nursing home that housed up to 84
people
and it was characterized by cells on
Long hallways with bars on the windows
with capacity for more than 500.
it was a dramatic change in the
treatment of families seeking Asylum who
were lawfully present in the United
States who had previously usually been
released into the community to await
their hearings
at Haro children of refugees awaited
awaiting hearings on Asylum claims were
denied schooling trapped all day in
cells either with unrelated adults or
their parents with no recreational
facilities
they weren't even allowed crayons or
pajamas
the ACLU and others filed lawsuits to
stop the separation of children and
other practices that it said were
prohibited under Florida's
resulting in a new settlement agreement
often again promising to minimize family
detention and the separation of children
and parents
foreign
oh wait I really do want that side
so in 2020 and particularly with the
covid-19 crisis the Trump Administration
began to actually accomplish what it had
long set out to win the effect of
unraveling of the Asylum system put in
place after World War II
first they learned what the Obama
Administration understood all along
which was that legal and bureaucratic
undermining of the system works better
than making children cry in front of
reporters and activists
beginning in 2019
Trump Administration took children from
their parents seeking Asylum under the
pretext that their parents were
criminals
there's not much history in the U.S of
Defending parents who've been
criminalized no matter how slight the
crime and the mass demonstrations in the
street and persistent editorials stopped
then they reactivated the obama-era
program of trying to stop Asylum seekers
in Mexico plan Frontera Sur
officially ice gave some people their do
their right to an asylum hearing but
metered their Crossing into the United
States then sent them back across the
border into Mexico to live in un
u.n-funded Refugee shelters and tent
cities to await hearings that never came
in the midst of the dangerous Landscapes
of the Border region
where many were victimized again by the
same transnational mafias and cartels
that they had fled in Central America
with the coveted crisis even these
limited forms of access to Refugee
hearings were reduced to the nearest
Trickle
border patrol agents were ordered to
deport to deport essentially any
non-citizen found near the border
including children under title 42.
of the public health code claiming that
their goal was to avoid exposing Asylum
Seekers to covid in congregate settings
ice essentially suspended the Asylum
system
and we will continue to need an asylum
system or something like it to address
the aftermath of wars in Central America
Decades of intervention by International
financial institutions and
non-governmental organizations that
shrunk and replaced the functions of
federal government in Central America
have
by Design dramatically weakened Central
American states in order to promote free
markets
power aborts a vacuum in the cartels
rushed in
local officials the police gangs and
international crime syndicates
syndicates increasingly became the same
entities often with the endorsement and
support of the Trump Administration
during
um during his presidency
murder rates for impoverished people at
the hands of all these groups
skyrocketed as they were increasingly
forced to pay for protection to drive a
taxi or run a store
people of humble means particularly
women queer queer and trans folk Youth
and children fled and droves seeking
asylum in the United States and Mexico
I want to conclude by way of this image
of a protest at Fort Sill where the
Trump Administration sought to house
1600 migrant children
Ford still began as A POW Camp during
the Indian Wars where the Apache leader
Geronimo died
a century later
it had it housed Japanese-American
detainees during World War II
this group pictured here a coalition of
members of the movement for black lives
Japanese Jewish and Native activists
step stopped it from becoming a
Detention Facility for migrant children
as we watch as a Biden Administration
tries to figure out whether it will
continue to expel thousands of people
and it is or honor its campaign promise
to listen to what the majority of people
in the United States actually want
which is an which is increased migration
adjust rapid Asylum system and a pathway
to citizenship rather than a racialized
labor system that can sign some people
to exploitative jobs and Fields
and people's homes threatened always
with the risk of losing their children
in order to keep them in line we need to
honor the history of protests Against
Child taking and remember that people in
every generation have stood against it
well stop there thanks
[Applause]
more than happy to take questions
foreign
thank you so much Professor
um this is great
um I have a question I guess about I
would love to hear your thoughts on the
racialization like the history of the
racialization of families
and
also the racialization of the border and
how this episode of zero tolerance
family separation is where those two
histories sort of intersect and if there
have been moments in the past your
lectures like speaks to that but I'd
love to hear
um your thoughts a little bit more on
that um yeah
thank you
um so the family has always been a
technology of racialization in the
United States it's
um it's remarkable given all the counter
evidence
um in front of us every day
um that we imagine families to be a site
where
um people are racially homogeneous right
and the other thing that we do with the
family is to see all non-nuclear
families as potentially also non-white
and
we know this through
um the image of a figure like The
Welfare Queen and her kin who also turns
up as sort of the anti-hero of the
culture poverty narrative
um the figure that centers
overpopulation which we were recently
reminded in the El Paso shooting is
still very much a live fantasy of white
nationalists
um obviously Eugenics
um in the 50s 60s and 70s was
a fierce account of racialization and
not just of people of color especially
earlier in the 20th century but also of
white folks of trying to produce
a healthy and pure white family right
without signs of visible signs of
disability
um
so I'm quite I've always been interested
in how we live the context of Empire
from inside Families how we live the
context of racialization how we live the
context of
um
of the economy from within families
and one of the things that so fascinated
me about what celesting did in our
missing Hearts which I mentioned at the
outset is that she manages to tell the
story of a dystopic white nationalist
future from inside families
um
and so the question of how we encounter
borders and bordering I think not just
in the US and the Southwest but as also
a site where we
um where we think family has been is
quite interesting to me as I and
horrifying
um as I sort of pursued these questions
one of the so we remember the Reagan Era
is the era of Traditional Values and and
today stuff and
um
fears about single mothers and seeing
that play out also as punishing fem
immigrant families who could not produce
themselves as nuclear right that only
certain people could pick up a child
from immigration detention and they had
to be a pretty near approximation of the
nuclear family
um not a cousin for example
and and we have a long history too of
encountering in the United States the
encounter between tribal Nations and U.S
racism has long been in terms of the the
problem of understanding a tribal
Community as not composed to nuclear
families and over and over again seeing
it sexualized and racialized and turned
into an object of War
through
um specifically thinking about patterns
of sexuality and family making
and of course the history of enslavement
is the history of telling us that of
slavers telling the story that black
mothers had no feelings for their
children and that's why they could be
sold apart
so that's a really long answer to your
question
do you want me to stand there can I sit
here hi um so I had a question and maybe
a little bit outside of um I don't know
maybe related more than I think but
um so recently there have been like all
these new technologies through which
um some of these children now as adults
have tried to reclaim those connections
and I'm thinking of in Argentina of all
the children who disappear DNA and all
of that can you just talk about what you
encounter in what you've read about that
and your thoughts on it sure
um so you know it's a transnational
effort by
um by
Physicians for human rights to actually
develop a technology that would allow
them to transform what in the 80s we had
good technology for being able to
identify
um through DNA who is your child right
that's still the only thing DNA by the
way is really good at all the stuff
where people tell you you can send your
DNA to some
um some bank and they'll tell you what
your ethnicity is
that's not what DNA is good for however
those banks are collecting tons and tons
of information that is being used by law
enforcement to tell stories about
families and relations
um and so to try to solve crimes through
identifying oh it must be this person's
son this person's half-brother
um
but so what
Physicians
um
Physicians for human rights sought to do
was to figure out if you could identify
the grandmother of somebody
particularly because it was groups
identifying as grandmothers that were at
the Forefront of the activism to recover
Argentina's lost children
and indeed they began to be able to
trace out those relationships
um and you know it was it was an amazing
effort that brought together people in
the U.S people in Argentina and people
throughout the throughout Latin America
who
um who developed these Technologies
together
so
one of the things that feels
um particularly Grim to me in the United
States right now is how difficult it
feels to
find find sources of opposition
to the growing white nationalism and so
and the fascinating thing is everybody
this is a side note sorry but
um everybody keeps talking about oh we
have to think about Hungary and Poland
and sure we can think about Hungary in
Poland but it's as if we don't live in
the hemisphere of the Americas like it's
as if we don't know how much these
ideologies were developed for the U.S
ruling class in relationship to Latin
America even the CNT trans stuff people
are like oh my God it's just like hungry
no oh my God it's just like Colombia oh
my God it's just like Latin America and
these people know each other they these
people are often related to each other
anyway so it's important to me
to stay in touch with Latin American
activists who have faced all of this for
decades
um with tremendous resources and
tremendous courage and even as
you know I don't mean to be flip about
this but we don't get killed much in
demonstrations and they do
um
and
I think they've faced much harsher
conditions than we have for their
activism
um with much greater courage than in
general people in the United States have
expressed and that's not to minimize
actually the um
the sheer level of violence that people
encountered in the summer of 2020 in the
black lives matter protests which I
still think we don't have a full I mean
we have the reports that tell us that
story but we don't have that as a shared
narrative
um that people were hurt and killed
regularly in those demonstrations by the
police but
um
by and large those kinds of experiences
are more the exception than the rule in
how
protest has been treated com in the
United States compared to how it's been
treated in Latin America
thank you thank you very much for your
talk even though you are telling a very
horrific and outraging story I was just
wondering what about the families that
have adopted these children are they
do they know what were the conditions
that allowed them to adopt and are they
openly or consciously complicit with
this story or what what's the story
there
yeah thanks for that question I went
back and forth about whether to talk
about it in the um Talk
um
so when I was in El Salvador talking to
the lawyers and the researchers at
proboscada they
um they talked about what it meant to
contact families in the United States
and
um for the most obviously humans are
incredibly diverse and there are many
different experiences
um for example
I'm not thinking of her name then title
of her book is missing Mila
um one adoptive parent of a Salvadoran
kid actually reached out to
um the family in Salvador and Honduras
and
um
fully
acknowledged what was her kids kind of
uh difficult to understand account of
um that and she very much had
um or he very much had parents alive in
El Salvador and relatives alive in El
Salvador
um and we also know the story from the
film discovering dominga of uh
Guatemalan young person whose sister was
a missionary
and you know so had good Spanish and a
lot of knowledge of Guatemala and as
um
dominga
kept talking about her experiences and
what she knew
um her sister was able to find her um
her community and her surviving
relatives so I say that as scaffolding
to say I want the lawyers in probinsk
could have told me is that the
overwhelming majority of U.S families
don't even want to acknowledge what
happened
um and only a handful of them are
willing to have contact
um
I've been starting to think more and
more about
um how foster care was built as such a
homophobic and transphobic institution
um why it's one of the most like
explicitly homophobic and transphobic
wings of the state and I think it's
related to
um why people may be really bad at
figuring out a relationship to these
Imperial relations which is to say that
um
Evangelical Christians have embraced
adoption embraced transnational adoption
so of Mormons but they've embraced it
within a particular Narrative of
exclusivity
and while that's certainly not all the
people who are involved in transnational
adoption it's a disproportionate number
of them
and while sometimes the experience of
understanding the ways and this is what
what I keep thinking about and why I
keep writing about it the ways that the
insides of families become complicit in
U.S Empire sometimes that's quite
disturbing and provocative to people in
the U.S or Europe but
for the most part all the energy that
goes into disavowing U.S Empire in
general is replicated by families
hi I'm a history PhD student and I've
noticed in the last several years in
that discipline there's been a move
towards using liberalism as a framework
for critiquing you know some of the
systems of society that we we least like
and you talk more yeah I'm losing it
right
um for example like there are some
Scholars who argue you know like
carcerality is a symptom of liberalism
in the liberal state of course the
challenge with that argument is that
there's non-liberal states that are
extremely cultural like China and Russia
for example and so I'm just curious if
you think that liberalism is a useful
framework for addressing for criticizing
the issues that you've raised is taking
children something that liberal regimes
do and that's the right entry point for
thinking about these things or is that
too limiting
I kind of as I was giving this talk I
kind of tripped over the part where I
said you know we need a good Asylum
system
um because the other way to say it is we
need to abolish the distinction between
immigrants and Asylum Seekers and that
it seems to me
um is
closer to what I certainly much closer
to what I hoped for but it seems further
away and so that's not what I said or
that's not what I wrote
um and it seems to me that that incar
that
encapsulates the problem with using
liberalism right there right
um liberalism is a widely shared
framework that we can use to develop
certain kinds of arguments that are
useful to certain people
but
um at the end of the day it's also the
problem right
um
and so of I think when you raise the
issue of culturality that's
um that's precisely the point that
liberalism with
um its relationship to capitalism and
its relationship to a certain account of
the family
um gives us this um
gives us a system
and so everyone's always an exception in
liberalism right
um and we've seen the Asylum and
immigration systems very much uh bigger
operate within the system as you know it
used to be that people
um
people who were approved for Asylum were
approved in blocks right
cambodians were
um because what we understood was that
people belong to a common situation
and what um
I'm now stumbling because I don't want
to like
what conservatives operating within
capital L liberalism
um understood is that liberalism's
genius is to turn everybody into an
individual over and over and over again
not even right they're they're what was
I wanted to see I'm thinking about that
church saying right there there are no
groups there are only family they're
individuals and their families
um and one of the things that fascinates
me about that line is so just finish out
the previous site
um
so now like zillions of lawyers have to
be deployed every to each and every
single Asylum case each and every
immigration case and they're never going
to be enough of us they're never enough
expert Witnesses
um it's just we've lost right once
everybody becomes an individual and not
that one shouldn't care about those
individuals of course but
um and their stories but that
um
this is how the system made it so
exceptional that Asylum and that Asylum
Seekers would be granted Asylum that
people would be approved as refugees
that people would be approved for an
immigration visa
um
but the other thing that's fascinating
about the Thatcher line is
um how much are households are important
to liberalism
and I could say a lot a lot about that
and I'm gonna try not to
um but
the
ways that we are in
um embedded in households only as
nuclear families right only nuclear
families count
um is another way of exceptionalizing
all sorts of people
um and indeed the majority of people in
the world are not nuclear families it's
ridiculous
um
so anyway individuals in their families
this is how liberalism operates
Laura I wanted just to follow up on that
um
you know you're part of your title of
your talk is about tactics of Terror and
it strikes me that you've
um
put a lot of focus today in the actual
talk about the terror throughout Latin
America much of it related to U.S Empire
in the book you also talk about Terror
tactics against particular racialized
communities within the United States
that you didn't Focus as much attention
on here native black
uh Latino and others and I just wanted
you to invite you to talk a little bit
about that now it may relate to this
question of individuation and family or
it may say something else about the
treatment of people as groups at moments
of emerging political influence or
radical threat right yes thank you for
that question
um so
one of the things so the thing I've been
trying to argue or the thing I tried to
argue in the book is that what we can
see is the use of the tactic of taking
children is that it has
um that it's always or
um a political tactic it is actually not
about individuals
and so I talk about the civil rights
movement and the moment of the explosion
and the size of the um
of the foster care system being in the
context of school desegregation and so
at the very moment that black
communities are using as a um the
strategy to sort of present themselves
in their Sunday Best
um in demonstrations as
as respectable people deserving of
citizenship and respect
um the tactic avoids premises was to
paint them as
disreputable particularly to focus on
single mothers and their children and so
using
um welfare and as a strat cutting off
welfare was a strategy to crush support
for civil rights or terrorized
communities
and um that in turn became a way of
separating children from their parents
by
um by basically starving single mothers
and their children
um and then the community would say well
you can't you can't take care of your
child
um and so that child should be placed in
foster care in the federal government
um actually pioneered that strategy
um in conversation with Southern States
um
I also talk about the ways that a
certain kind of abortion politics were
pioneered in relationship to the
so-called um War on Drugs
and so the accusation that pregnant
women were using drugs or especially in
Native communities that pregnant women
were drinking excessively
um both of these were
um
where it Bears saying lies
um I want to say as often as I can
because it so still is troubling
cocaine has no effect on a pregnancy
this hysteria about crack babies was
entirely ginned up
and
um but what the what prosecutors were
doing ambitious anti-abortion
prosecutors were doing was trying to
produce an account of fetal personhood
um that we now see running rampant
through the wind as an account of why
women can have autonomy women in trans
folks can have autonomy over their
bodies even if there's a six-week fetus
the size of a lentil
um inside it
if you're carrying around a a person
inside your body
um you become subject to the protection
of that
that person by the state
um and that was always the point
and
um
sometimes people ask me well so why was
the state trying to save producing this
rhetoric about saving black babies and
saving native babies
um and
it seems to me that it never
particularly cared about
um saving black babies or saving native
babies so much as it cared about using
um
depriving black and native women of
Rights and sending them to prison and
jail for um for being pregnant
as a sort of trial run for how to push
into abortion politics in the United
States
um
and I talk also about fights for the
Indian Child Welfare act
um and laws to limit or not laws but
policies to limit the placement of black
foster kids and white adoptive homes
and the fights against those in the
1990s and still
um the fifth circuit just handed down a
decision that seems to threaten the
Indian Child Welfare act and
you know I want to say
that's so crazy like you can't do that
right the claim that what the Indian
Child Welfare act does is produce native
people is a
um a racial group and that's improper
um it does no such thing it produces
native people as members of a particular
polity and those members of tribal
Nations it's very explicit about that
but what
um the last few years have taught me is
to stop believing that crazy [ __ ]
doesn't happen
um in the courts
sorry I couldn't get through that
sentence without the curse but
um so that's some of the the rest of it
[Music]
um
I point out what I think we don't say
enough which is
Indian boarding schools were started by
the war department
um they were started as a strategy to
address Indian Wars they were meant to
terrorize people
and then they were subsequently
um
supplemented with
um
with religious schools by the Catholic
Church the Mormons and other Christian
groups but you know it's important to
remember that like Carlisle Indian
School most famous of Indian schools
what is it now it's the
um it's an army war College it never
stopped being a military facility and in
fact the legal basis under which
um
Trump could give an executive order for
um for Asylum Seekers to lose their kids
at the border without being legally
challenged was precisely the same basis
under which
um the Indian boarding schools were
enacted as a federal policy so these
things are very much tied up with each
other and we are still living their
legacy
queer families are losing their kids
again they always were
um
they
um but it was for a time
um black and latinx queer families that
were mostly losing their kids
and now it's you know very white
middle-class parents in Texas of trans
kids
um who are saying wait I'm the sort of
person you want to be a foster parent
sorry they're people I follow on Twitter
and I'm like please stop
um please don't do that but
um you find but it's actually
fascinating to find coalitions in Texas
between
um
the anti-carceral activists who want to
end what they call the Family regulation
system and the foster care system with
very conservative
evangelicals who want to homeschool
their kids without interference from the
state any and together with them are
these middle class parents of trans kids
so
the state will ultimately come after an
awful lot of people and perhaps there's
some hope in that that we can build
meaningful coalitions
um
like that one but also others
um to to stop the taking of children
hey um I was really curious to know
um about child taking in Honduras child
taking in Honduras and also if you could
talk a little bit about why in El
Salvador there were more cases of
recovering
um children than in some of the other
countries if you could just talk a
little bit more about sure that could be
Civil Society
um the ability to
build the Civil Society group that could
reach across the whole country
um
and everybody in El Salvador more or
less speak Spanish and
the um
also the fact that
the
the I'm trying to think of a word that
does some justice a very conservative
um
military members and
um members of the dictatorship stayed in
power
um in Guatemala and so it was extremely
difficult to
um
it was extremely difficult to build
anything in Guatemala That Couldn't
immediately be torn apart I also think
that the depth of people's fears of each
other in Guatemala is as especially as
indigenous communities were pitted
against each other
um it remains a really Salient thing the
other thing is human rights activists
are still getting killed by the police
in the military in Guatemala if you want
to do this work you're facing
imprisonment or death
um I started doing research in Guatemala
about the time that um
somebody in gender studies at the
University of Central America got
disappeared for doing this research and
I was like oh oh
um and you know hoping that being having
the protections of sort of a U.S embassy
which we knew was complicit but
nevertheless having the the
um
the kind of
the thing about being white and U.S
American
gave me some protection but it didn't
for everybody
so it's complicated
Laura thank you so much
um you've given me so much to think
about
I want to think with you and just ask
you to talk a little bit more about the
status
of the child in these different forms of
child taking
um
and
I'm struck that in
that narrative about the
making sure that when you take the child
you are canceling the future right and
it seems to me that
um
what is also the present right now
is we're also living through all of
these other
you not only have these cases of actual
taking right
and the loss
but that the law has made it and the
exercise of law enforcement
um
has also been a way of
holding us in a process of a lot of
other kinds of child taking or child
taking in potential
and I was thinking about the TPS debates
that are happening right now
and how that is uh slowly unfurling
process of family separation
um I was on a call this morning because
I'm in giving testimony for a Asylum
case for an Honduran family
a woman
and she will likely be deported because
her four kids now have
individually
gotten Asylum papers
and so the judge has decided that
because those kids are safe
extensively safe they're going to go
into foster care
she can be deported
and so in some cases of what you were
looking at the child is the direct
Target of violence just they themselves
like when we put kids
in lock up with adults and say they're
MS-13 and their animals doesn't matter
that they're 11 doesn't matter they're
13.
um
sometimes
it's to hold them told the parents
hostage
but in so many of these cases the cases
of genociding with them I love the
killing of political enemies I just want
to ask you just sort of how you think
about the different statuses of the
child in those different acts of
child taking because one of the things
that your study shows us is just how
extraordinary flexible
this form of Terror is and how
just it weaves itself through the
society and then the cartels reproduce
the child taking in their own operations
I just I'm just really inviting you to
say more because it's so powerful what
you've been sharing thank you
I know one of the things I've thought a
lot about is
um or maybe not enough about is that I'm
actually much better at thinking about
the ways that child separation is about
the adults
um and I think in that I am
following the so many of the policy
makers and
um ideologues who are
um producing the rationale for child
taking
um but at the same time
it's really clear that
it's not like once they get the child
then they imagine a Humane future for
the child right
um on the contrary
they imagine that
um that gay kids will go through
conversion therapy that trans kids will
not go it will not transition they
imagine that
um
Spanish-speaking kids will be placed
with
um Anglo families who don't speak
Spanish
they um
there were some people commenting from
the Trump Administration I was really
trying to figure out like what were they
thinking
um and
so to some extent they were like I don't
know I guess we just thought they'd go
to
um DHS and like no and you know they
disappear and like there was no way to
imagine
children and I always sort of like want
to vomit when I get to when I think
about Scalia and conservatives claiming
that children and immigration detention
who there was so much visceral testimony
that I didn't want to quote right it's
like it's horrible and I don't want to
sort of produce the trauma
um is but
that they then turned around and said
well of course it's fine to detain
children as long as conditions are
Humane and obviously they are
and like
how like how do you even sort of think
that say that
um
so
part of what's always fascinated me is
the vanishing of children like the
imagination that they will you know
be be produced as I don't know little
white Americans or something
um
and
but
it's
and this you know the story you tell
from this morning
I wish I could say it surprises me at
all you know there was a moment of
course as you know we all know when the
when having children
was a reason to stay
because it was cruel to children to
leave them to separate them from their
parents
um
right
and it's been now decades and Decades of
um of you know you can do anything you
want to parents when if the if you can
produce any account at all in which the
children are sort of okay and you think
me want to bang my head against a while
when I'd hear
um conservatives start talking about
anchor babies at precisely the moment
when there was no such thing anymore
right it's like how does this so anyway
you've reached the level at which I'm
completely incoherent and speechless I
don't know how to
you've been incredibly coherent and um
but you know um given us a lot to dwell
on and um I want to thank you for your
book
um which I hope I know many people have
read and would urge everyone to read and
thank you for being here
um and I know you'll be seeing some
people tomorrow as well during your stay
on campus so we're grateful for that as
well and thank you to everybody who made
this event possible please join me in
thanking Laura Briggs
[Applause]
[Music]